pourquoi taylor une verge un jet protège
la beauté des pillards parce que mon
boss et plus assurer qu'entre la purge
depuis hier mais il faudrait changer ça
sénatrice les sociétés d'assurances arma
crise honnête travailleur et toi comment
tu t'appelles tu sais quoi monsieur
l'agent secret tu ferais mieux de
remercier ce bon vieux des gros buts à
sauver plutôt que de l'interroger et
s'appelle jeudi que joe dickson racheter
au français ou un mec juste un peu rien
à cirer tes états d'âme j'espérais du
respecte les verts jusqu'en mai prochain
buteur s'il vous plaît regardez
m c'est quoi ça c'est le pire dont j'ai
parlé c'est la purge puisque vous
espériez